[Musique]
y at il un risque de désobéissance
civile le hashtag je ne me rends compte
qu'ils n'auraient pas à prendre
l'ampleur ces derniers jours il a donc
décidé de désobéir et incite d'autres
restaurateurs à faire de l
je moi je suis là je suis un élément
déclencheur je pense qu'on pourrait
découvrir des rébellions de gens qu'on
n'imagine pas avoir protesté tellement
ils sont fatigués la préfecture a
annoncé que les personnes présentes
avaient été ou seront verbalisés le
restaurateur lui a été placé en garde à
vue pour avoir employé un cuisinier
étrangers en situation irrégulière je
dirais emmanuel macron non seulement de
ne pas aller vers cette folie dur
confinement médard était aussi de
boucler la france d' arrêter ce carnage
les éléments qui sont en conseil de
défense je demande qu'il soit sur la
place publique pour que l'on sache
exactement contamination ou pas dans les
écoles les inconvénients pour les
enfants de ne pas aller à l'école sont
énormes donc on ne doit pas brader
l'école et les gens qui vont sur les
plateaux pour très facilement
brad et l'école font plus de mal que de
bien on a fait un choix qui est celui de
maintenir le plus possible les écoles
ouvertes et je vais vous dire ce choix
on en est fiers parce que c'est ce qui
permet une continuité éducative pour nos
enfants et on va en parler de ce qu il
pense
les recettes les dépenses donc non
monsieur castex et non monsieur le maire
[Musique]
je ne serai pas là l'année prochaine les
français ne pourront pas vivre
durablement au rythme des confinement
des déconfinement der confinement des
couvre-feux à 20 eur puis à 18 heures
etc etc
ça n'est pas possible monsieur macron si
les décisions avaient été prises
autrement
plutôt que de nous faire miroiter des
ouvertures à certaines dates
les dégâts ne serait pas aussi important
que ça quant aux quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est assez facile à comprendre
et c'est très facile de voir qu'on est
très loin du compte
l'information fait froid dans le bas du
dos la chine effectué des tests recto
pour détecter le coc vide
selon des médias nationaux les habitants
de plusieurs quartiers de pékin ont dû
s'y soumettre
tout comme des touristes étrangers
placés en quarantaine cette fête se
déroule dans la salle de repos du
commissariat d'aubervilliers
au moins huit personnes réunies dans
cette pièce qui ne doit pas en
accueillir plus de 6 à cause des
restrictions sanitaires
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus ils sont
venus célébrer la mutation du mieux de
nantes
les participants ne porte pas le masque
ne respectent pas la distanciation le
tout en plein couvre-feu va pas
continuer dans les années qui viennent à
penser que allez on a eu la crise du
siècle et que ça ne se reproduira pas ça
fait bien longtemps qu'on sait que les
pandémies peuvent justement évolué et
qu'il peut y avoir des mutations et je
pense que nous n'avons pas fini avec ces
risques ces risques sanitaires
c'est un projet qui vous est attribuée
vouloir installer un installé à
l'occasion de la vaccination contre le
coc vide une puce sous la peau pour
tracer et contrôler la population
mondiale
d'où sa vie ans a désormais en pologne
l'avortement n'est autorisé que dans de
rares cas très précis en cas de viol ou
d'inceste ou si la vie de la mère est en
danger
rien de ce que en quoi je suis impliqué
fans implique des puces rayden sous la
peau des gens aillent de suivre les
jauges comprends pas la logique pourquoi
est ce que je serai impliqué là dedans
notre fondation fait des vaccinations
effets des vaccins pour sauver des vies
décision qui a suscité vous l'avais dit
la colère de milliers de manifestants
dans plusieurs villes du pays en fait ça
fait des mois qu'il se bat contre cette
décision